thank you
you love watching clips of anime mentors
being cool and making all those flashy
entrances well how about for today's
list we do something quite similar yet
slightly different maybe talk about
something that's quite often conjoined
with the legendary entrance the first
impression today's list will be going
over what I think are some of the best
First Impressions by an anime Mentor the
points will be done in no order so feel
free to rank them in your heads oh and
if you want to share your personal
rankings the comment section is the way
to go let's begin Goro Sensei is one of
the First characters to cross my mind
when we think of impactful First
Impressions we often think of badass
Feats you know said Mentor being there
to One-Shot the super powerful enemy or
something like that for someone like
gonor Sensei though his first impression
came like a soft playful tune it's just
a big weird alien thing acting as a
teacher before he gets ambushed by
students wielding literal assault rifles
what I like about this scene is that it
establishes several things at once it
opens questions as to why the students
are trying to shoot him down but more
importantly the casual and nonchalant
way he addresses the class really speaks
to establishing his personality he also
seems overly friendly to his supposed
Killers that's a good preview to what's
to come and how big of a part he'll be
in these students lives a bit of flex in
here and there but it's not the
bombastic first impression you'd
typically expect from an overpowered
Mentor no super special techniques or
narration that overblows his power yet
still it does several things very well
all at the same time
the things won't stay subdued for ever
as our next entry is Lisa Lisa
Isa Lisa first appeared in JoJo as an
unassuming woman on a boat she then
wasted no time showing off her skills
all while we get a lot of verbal hype I
think that Lisa Lisa is quite slept on
as a character with a cast as large as
JoJo's full of powerful characters it's
easy to find this Mentor lost in the
shuffle however after learning more
about her relationship with Joseph we
can now view this scene with a different
perspective she's a very cool character
overall and this scene gives her the
right amount of hype as well as give a
sense of intrigue to first-time viewers
who don't know who she is
foreign
legendary mentors deserve nothing more
than legendary titles like master sensei
Lord and whatnot thankfully you can
enjoy the same perks in real life thanks
to today's sponsor established titles
established titles is a Nifty way to
help preserve Scotland's Lush woodlands
and the world's reforestation efforts
how do you do so by buying title packs
that will entitle you to one square foot
of dedicated land in Scotland
specifically edelstone you'll get a
certificate that will officially give
you the title Lord or Lady based on the
Scottish custom of naming landowners it
even features a unique plot Number with
which you can see the exact location of
your land what's more for every order
you can help establish titles plant a
tree who've partnered with one tree
planted and trees for the future to
support Global reforestation efforts
let's all take part in this fun activity
for a cause and this would be an
excellent way to give your friend a last
minute surprise present too oh and the
first 200 people to purchase a title
will get their land next to my plot so
we can start building our very own
Vinnie tube Kingdom from there
established titles is also running a
massive Black Friday sale so if you use
the code Vinnie you get an additional 10
off how cool is that a go to
establishtitles.com Vinnie and become a
lord now
so we got one of the most powerful
members of the fire force here what kind
of introduction does he get one where he
gets to easily front his snarky and
disrespectful demeanor quickly setting
him apart from all the other captains
and making him stand out to the audience
we know that someone with that kind of
attitude has to have a way to back it up
he's the strongest one out there but
he's got to prove it soon right it's
those kinds of interesting questions
that make a good debut and I think for
all the short time that Benny Maru has
on screen he got us all asking those
things a good first impression is also
how well someone makes the most out of
the limited time on screen to create
more hooks more prospective scenarios in
the audience's mind making them more
immersed in Following the show and
seeing more of what he can do for
someone with such a standoffish attitude
like Benny Maru who will soon get his
development and first chance to Showcase
his skills this is one great debut scene
all might makes a very impactful
appearance in the next scene
enter to these kind of things we often
allude to the climactic scene in the
first season where he saves everyone but
he's been doing it for way too long
already like this scene where he goes
after the sludge villain cornering it
while it's in the process of seizing
midoriya's body there we get the
signature silhouette the signature line
and the signature ass kicking that
follows he easily handles the sludge
with an all while looking as powerful
and Peerless as he can be that were to
make a strong impression on anyone
watching the scene and it didn't even
matter that he defeated a nothing
villain instead of someone named it's an
impactful debut but none got moved by it
more than midoriya himself this is an
entrance that would spark the start of
the whole plot and to that extent the
beginnings of a new Legend doesn't get
more impactful than that now does it
next we have a relative newcomer to the
whole anime thing it's Gojo
Gojo has made a career out of being
awesome but is that too unexpected given
his strong showing as early as his first
appearance I don't think so he starts
out pretty chill a stark contrast to the
magumi who's ready to fight to the death
and that alone is already quite the show
of strength as strange as it may sound
to some he's completely in control of
the situation and even dare suguna to
try his best shot all while toying with
the curse and knocking Yuji out like it
was nothing with Gojo having so many
awesome Feats that just make you go wow
you think that eventually he'll be due
to the standard mental Trope of getting
destroyed just to give the hero some
motivation but no that doesn't happen he
continues staying awesome and living up
to the feeling of being the strongest
and we can see from here that he's
always been that way heck you can even
go back to the prequel movie Jiu Jitsu
Kaizen zero and save he never even lost
a step
following that we have a less
conventional mentor utsuro
I say less conventional because utsuro
while technically being a mental
character is actually the main villain
of Gintama it's the first villainous
example we have on this list so far but
I just can't help but include him
considering how much momentum and hype
he got out of his debut one thing I'll
always love about this first appearance
is how low-key he was throughout the
whole thing it's like Lisa Lisa earlier
but this one had actual consequences for
the good guys nabume Sogo and gagura
don't stand a chance and I bet those
three didn't know what hit them before
it's too late just who is this random
mask guy why is he so strong it's like
those moments in video games when you
just get beaten down by a random mooc
that's somehow so strong before
revealing itself to be something else
even in Tokyo to suffer his own
breakdown upon tearing down that mask
it's a first appearance that left more
than one of the main casts emotionally
scarred for a while and that's her first
great impression to remember both for us
and the characters
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
that several of us would most fondly
remember his entrance in the auction
house you remember that yeah right after
Luffy made the punch heard around the
world but his actual first appearance in
the story was a bit more low-key yet
just as powerful sure he didn't make his
presence felt in a big loud way but the
way he saved Cami should have had you
all wondering what's up with this old
guy I think that's one of the very
effective ways to build up Intrigue for
a character you're about to introduce an
important mentor of that too the way he
displayed conqueror haki also got us
thinking more about the ability and how
it will impact the overall direction of
the story moving forward it's probably
not as fondly remembered as his grand
entrance or the Luffy moment both which
follow this one shortly but it's here to
remind everyone that before all those
big moments we already knew that there's
something special about this Rayleigh
what's your
subscribe
so there you have it my top anime mental
First Impressions hope you enjoyed
seeing these scenes that felt more
nostalgic than I expected when coming up
with the entries and thanks to
established titles for sponsoring
today's video check the link in the
description and become a lord now that's
gotta do it for now though have a good
day thanks for watching and I hope to
see you again for the next video